البيانات الجديدة الصادرة اليوم هي بعض من
نفس البيانات التي دفعت مركز السيطرة على الأمراض
لتغيير
توجيهاته الجماعية في وقت سابق من هذا الأسبوع مراكز الاكتشاف المحورية الخاصة به
حول تفشي مرغوب فيه في
ولاية ماساتشوستس
حيث لا يزال الأشخاص الملقحون
مصابين على الرغم من أننا بحاجة إلى التأكيد
على أن اللقاح يمكن أن يحافظ على مرض خطير  في
الخليج ،
لكن لا يزال بإمكان هؤلاء الأفراد أن يصبحوا
معديين جدًا للآخرين.
غير الملقحين ولكن
أيضًا الملقحين بالكامل نتعلم
أن نوع دلتا من الفيروس التاجي
أكثر عدوى
كما هو الحال مع جدري الماء
مما يعني أن شخصًا
مصابًا بالدلتا يمكن أن ينتشر
في المتوسط إلى ثمانية أو تسعة أشخاص بد
اً من اثنين أو ثلاثة فقط  الأشخاص
المصابون بالسلالة
الأصلية للفيروس ولذا تتذكر في وقت سابق من
هذا الأسبوع إعلان القرص المضغوط عن
إرشادات جديدة  على كتلة تقول إن الجميع
بغض النظر عن
حالة التطعيم يحتاجون إلى ارتداء قناع بينما في
الداخل جيدًا ، كان جزء من ذلك يعتمد على
كما قلت
هذه الدراسة من تفشي المرض في
بروفينستاون بولاية ماساتشوستس حيث
أصيب 469 شخصًا في مايو آسف في يوليو 75
74 من  حدثت الحالات الإجمالية بين
الأشخاص الذين تم تطعيمهم بالكامل
ووجدوا أن
أكثر من 100 من
الأشخاص الذين تم تطعيمهم بالكامل والذين أصيبوا بفيروس دلتا
لديهم نفس القدر من الفيروس في أنظمتهم مثل
الأشخاص الذين لم يتم
تلقيحهم وهذا هو السبب في مطالبة مركز السيطرة على الأمراض
بتغييره.  إرشادات الإخفاء
لأنها تُظهر
أنه حتى إذا تم تطعيمك ، فقد
تنشر متغير دلتا
من فيروس دلتا حول شيء واحد
يؤكده الخبراء وهو أن اللقاح لا
يزال يجعلك أكثر أمانًا ولكنه لا
يزال وقائيًا للغاية في هذه الحالة  من
بروفينستاون ، أربعة فقط من الملقحين
المطلوب دخولهم المستشفى ، كان اثنان من هؤلاء
الأشخاص يعانون من ظروف صحية أساسية
ولم يتوف أحدهم آخر  نقطة الراحة
هنا يقدر مركز السيطرة على الأمراض أن هناك 35000 إصابة
مصحوبة بأعراض
بين الذين تم تطعيمهم بالكامل
كل أسبوع ،
وهذا يمنحك حقًا إحساسًا
بما يحدث هنا مع هذا
البديل الجديد ويجعل
البروتوكولات مثل التباعد الجماعي والتباعد الاجتماعي
أكثر إلحاحًا